okay wir haben ja oceana und leon taylor
aus hessen oder ist das überhaupt
richtig sei dabei dass es wichtig ist
richtig also liehen ist
gebürtiger hesse und ich mag es hin wie
wird man gast gast es in ganz wird man
wenn man einen wellness zimmer in
darmstadt hat die beste frau in meiner
mutter wohnt in darmstadt und da habe
ich ein zimmer hin außerdem habe ich
wunderbare erinnerungen und ganz
gravierende große momente in meinem
leben haben in hessen statt gefunden
deshalb bin ich wirklich ein wirklicher
gast hesse ich war das erst mal auf der
bühne auf der großen bühne mit maceo
parker in darmstadt in der
zentralstation
und fabienne in hessen kennengelernt
nachdem ich mit peter fox auf torwart
weil ich eine vorgruppe in der
jahrhunderthalle und danach waren party
und
dann haben wir gesungen und werden ja
und erstmal hier
also ist es nicht von der plattenfirma
irgendwie inszeniert das denkmal gemacht
die und dann machen wir das und das muss
ja für hessen und dann muss es dabei
sein und dann ja ich hatte halt das dass
das glück dass also wir werden ja da
auch schon uns vorher so ein bisschen
auf myspace und sondern haben uns
getroffen in frankfurt und und dann
wollten wir irgendwie schon immer was
machen und dann kam auch schon mit dem
song also dann aber eine ewigkeit später
an gepäck
wie hat man einen song im gepäck wie
weil ich am anfang des jahres war ich in
los angeles und habe an meinem neuen
album gearbeitet und da ist habe ich
auch vor wayne geschrieben mit meinen
produzenten zusammen
und irgendwie dachte ich immer als ich
den song gehört habe das würde sich gut
als duett und
und dann kam irgendwann zurück und ich
kannten und wir waren auch so in kontakt
und dann habe ich lernen irgendwann mal
den song geschickt man kann auch diese
ganze geschichte bundesvision song
contest und dann haben wir eigentlich
erst auch angefangen da dran rum zu
probieren wie könnte man das wirklich
umsetzen diese idee und dann auch mit
diesem arzt würde sich ja dann gut
eignen du willst ja auch gern damit
machen ich würde auch gerne mitmachen
zusammen ist man eher stärker hamburg
war schon belegt hessen war noch frei
klein beigegeben ja wie man das mädchen
oft machen muss oder ob er wirklich mit
nach hessen helfen ja immerhin auch kein
stolz drauf also weil ich rheinhessen
also frankfurt vor allem es auch einfach
eine geile stadt und
warum möchte man beim bundesvision song
contest mitmachen damit mal ganz berühmt
es ist eine super super show wo man live
spielen kann wo viele gute künstler
dabei sind die auch irgendwie lange
dabei sind und ernsthaft an ihrer
karriere arbeiten ist auch einfach zu
einer wichtigen stoffe für
musik in deutschland geworden also so
wie es
mal war
aber jetzt mal im ernst also es ist
einfach ist ja aus einem spaß heraus
entstanden die ganze idee aber es ist
doch echt zu einer wichtigen sendung
geworden und ich glaube da kann man ganz
stolz sein ein bundesland zu vertreten
wir sind doch nicht nur politiker
sondern vertreten haben die bundesländer
und wünsche wir vertreten hessel und
zählen auch auf hessen übrigens wer es
noch wann wird es gepostet hier anrufen
was ich auch noch dazu sagen muss nicht
nur anrufen sondern auch hier auf
youtube dieses video natürlich nach oben
bringen weil dann
kriegen auch ganz viele mit dass es euch
gibt das essen gibt und dass das ein
geiler titel ist also favorisieren das
video so oft gucken wie es geht und fans
ab für dieses video und
wir alle drücken die daumen für euch
gibt es schon wetten
generell nicht vor allem nicht um geld
da gibt es schon wetten wo er so landen
werden oder was für chance gehabt was
was denkt ihr wenn er abends ins bett
geht und so überlegt und an den bundes
die ansprechpartnerin leben was denkst
du wenn
ich an oskar und
natürlich wollen wir ganz weit vorne mit
dabei sein - es wird auf jeden fall eine
großartige party
ich glaube das ist auch
haben wir werden sehr samstag oder
freitag wissen und aber wir freuen uns
einfach auf die bühne auf die
performance
die jungs oder band sie anderen musiker
die anderen werden sie sind ja auch
letztendlich kollegen also leute die wir
sitzen alle im gleichen boot also eine
große party frage obwohl ich denke aus
ghana könnt könnt gewinnen ich gerne
auch also strikt lehrer noch die also
ist mein favorit
ist hier
mein favorit ok viel erfolg